Sonic is back with a bold New Direction
in Sonic Frontiers Sonic Frontiers takes
cues from Modern open world games to
create something both familiar and all
new for Sonic so here is everything you
need to know about Sonic Frontiers
[Music]
Sonic Frontiers is being directed by
morio Kishimoto of Sonic team and the
same director behind 2017 Sonic forces
while Sonic forces garnered relatively
negative to average reviews with a meta
score rating of 57 and a 6.5 from users
it seems Kishimoto really took the
criticisms of the game to Heart in an
interview with Game Informer he revealed
that in 2022 he'd been on Sonic team for
19 years and that he intended to learn
from both the successes and failures of
every Sonic game from Sonic forces in
particular he noted that shorter stages
pulling back on Sonic's speed a little
and implementing new actions wasn't
satisfying fans producer Takashi izuka
stated he wants Frontiers to feel like a
bold New Direction for Sonic and a
template for future Sonic games similar
to how Sonic Adventure had set the
template for future 3D Sonic games while
it looks and feels similar to breath of
the wild with the inspiration seeming to
be fairly apparent current Kishimoto
refers to Sonic Frontiers not as an open
world game but rather an open zone game
after summer game Fest 2022 it was
revealed the game has a larger open Zone
Hub with cyberspace areas within
containing traditional Sonic stages
[Music]
as I mentioned there are essentially two
different parts to the gameplay the open
Zone which is what first got attention
for being such a new departure for the
Sonic formula and the cyberspace zones
open zone areas include multiple puzzles
you'll need to solve along with
platforming side quests and The Game's
new combat system bosses also exist in
the open zones for Sonic to battle each
zone is absolutely massive and meant to
allow the player to explore as they want
and play in the style they want brand
new to Sonic with Sonic Frontiers is a
skill tree Fallen enemies now drop skill
pieces Sonic can collect and used to
upgrade his skills not only that but
Sonic will be able to upgrade his stats
by collecting red seeds of power and
blue seeds of Defense these seeds can be
found by completing puzzles and side
quests in the open zones these puzzles
can also unlock new areas of the map
combat is another new feature to Sonic
Frontiers while Sonic will maintain his
classic skill of a harming attack he'll
also have a drop Dash and stop attack be
able to slide at any point and boost his
speed on on ground or mid-air not only
that the Sonic can now attack with his
fists in melee combat perform Combos and
use the brand new skill tree to level up
these skills sciloop is another new
ability that from my experience playing
at summer game Fest 2022 unlocks early
on siloop sees you run in a circle
around an enemy while activating this
ability in order to break enemies
Shields and guards then have an opening
to get in attacks sileup can also be
used to quickly collect Rings after
getting hit by an enemy Sonic can also
now both Parry enemy attacks and Dodge
parrying allows Sonic to use this window
to counter attack meanwhile dodging at
the right time briefly slows down time
allowing Sonic to get in more attacks
included in Sonic's new skill set is a
meter that will fill up during Combos
and when high enough allows Sonic to
perform a phantom Rush which boosts
Sonic's attack power until the meter
drops back to zero another new attack is
Sonic Boom
sadly not the song Sonic Boom from the
Sonic CD but rather a brand new ranged
attack that shoots out shock waves while
Rush is an attack that sends Sonic's
zigzagging to avoid attacks and crash
into the enemy while there are basic
enemies Sonic will be up against there's
also much larger boss-like enemies
called Guardians many of these have
unique ways to be defeated and utilize
Sonic's platforming similar in a way to
say Shadow of the Colossus one such
Guardian might see Sonic running up his
giant tendrils to attack its top while
another might Force Sonic to grind along
giant rings encircling its insides in
order to open up a weak point for
defeating bosses Sonic will obtain
portal gears portal gears allow Sonic to
unlock the other half of the game the
cyberspace stages these are classic
Sonic stages and each one contains
numerous challenges for you to complete
by doing so Sonic will be able to obtain
Vault Keys which can in turn be used to
unlock chaos Emerald's vaults it would
be a Sonic game without Super Sonic and
in Sonic frontier's Tokyo game show
trailer it was revealed that Sonic could
once again collect chaos emeralds and
eventually utilize these to turn into
supersonic Frontiers also features a
couple different modes in order to
increase accessibility players can
choose between at least two different
modes action and high speed mode which
Alters how Sonic feels and controls
additionally there's a mode that allows
players to turn on auto combos where
tapping a single button will make Sonic
perform as various combos against
enemies
[Music]
Angel Island is the home to the Master
Emerald and watched over by Knuckles who
is chosen for this solitary Duty as it
turns out thousands of years prior his
Echidna ancestors had tried to steal the
power of the Master Emerald so he feels
watching over the emerald could be an
atonement for his ancestors sins
Knuckles makes it his quest to explore
Angel Island for every and any possible
vulnerability to the chaos emeralds and
discover the origin of the master
Emerald's Powers who built this Shrine
to the emeralds
[Music]
go
in doing so he finds a mysterious Cog
and Shrine after placing the Cog he's
warped the way to a desolate Island
filled with mysterious metallic beings
and a strange character with the power
to lock him away in a prison according
to the overview trailer Sonic has left
for the Starfall Islands to collect the
chaos emeralds with Amy and Tails when
they're sucked into a dimensional portal
where Sonic is separated from his
friends Landing in cyberspace he's able
to escape to Kronos Island and discovers
tails and Amy's seem to have been
captured by the same Force as knuckles
he encounters the mysterious figure who
locked away Knuckles who seems to think
they're protecting the world asking
Sonic to submit and leave immediately it
seems this character may also be in
charge of the massive Guardians and
likely has something to do with the
secret of the Ancients which is likely
the power behind the Chaos Emeralds
Sonic Frontiers releases on November 8th
for Nintendo switch PS5 PS4 Xbox series
X slash S Xbox One and steam for sixty
dollars you can pick up the standard
edition while 70 will get you the
digital deluxe edition for pre-ordering
either one you'll get an adventurous
treasure box which includes skill points
Red Seas of power and blue Seas of power
so seemingly a head start to your stats
the digital deluxe edition exclusively
comes with the Explorer's treasure box
which contains Amy's memory tokens a
portal gear cast Emerald Vault keys and
additional gloves and shoes for Sonic
not only that but you'll also get a
digital art book and 25 track digital
mini soundtrack and that wraps up
everything you need to know about Sonic
Frontiers are you looking forward to the
game and out of curiosity what was the
last 3D Sonic game you played let us
know in the comments below and I'll see
you next time
foreign